los modelos lineales y cuadráticas
tienen mucho ritmo aprendamos algunos
pasos de baile con estos modelos
si no sabes bailar no te preocupes
empezaremos con los lineales
la función lineal f x es igual a x es la
más sencilla de las funciones lineales
porque el valor de la función es el
mismo que el de x
si x aumenta también efe x por lo tanto
es una función creciente para el paso de
baile nos colocamos al centro es decir
sobre el eje vertical y ponemos nuestros
brazos como si fueran cada lado de la
gráfica para el siguiente movimiento
tomaremos la función inversa es decir f
x es igual a menos x esta gráfica es
decreciente porque va hacia abajo y el
valor de x en la función es negativo
haciendo el paso completo nuestro
movimiento quedaría así cuando subimos
un brazo bajamos el otro de arriba hacia
abajo de manera alternada y con estas
gráficas podemos representar una
proporción directa en la creciente y una
proporción inversa en la decreciente
cuando nuestro modelo lineal incluye
valores absolutos tendremos gráficas
como ésta que resultan de la función f x
es igual a valor absoluto de x y ésta es
una función feliz mira cómo quedan tus
brazos en este paso de baile tiene un
segmento decreciente pero después crece
y eso es genial
su contraparte es la función de menos
valor absoluto de x queda justo al revés
porque aquí primero crece y luego
decrece
así que este paso con valores absolutos
queda de esta manera
nuestro último movimiento está
conformado por pasos de baile con
modelos cuadráticas básicos
empezamos con fx es igual a x al
cuadrado
esta gráfica nos da el siguiente
movimiento de baile deja fluir tus
brazos para lograr la curva que
representa de crecimiento y crecimiento
exponencial ahora la función de raíz de
x la cual solo tiene valores positivos
para ambos lados de la gráfica y nos
permite mover un brazo
el paso de baile queda justo así con
mucho ritmo y el último movimiento será
el completo de esta gráfica es decir los
valores para raíz de x negativa esta
gráfica la obtenemos con efe de x es
igual a raíz de menos x y ahora le toque
el otro brazo representar la gráfica
vemos cómo queda el paso de las
cuadráticas que representan cambios en
un valor de manera exponencial tanto
para aumentar como para disminuir esta
increíble repasemos la coreografía
completa te invito a desarrollar tus
propios pasos con las gráficas que
tengas te sorprenderá a los rítmicas que
pueden ser